so what could I do here with this I'm
going to wipe the whole slate clean and
stuff in this again what can I do before
I go to tea results in order to make
this something that's workable yeah yeah
very good so a few people suggested this
and this is helpful because when you
have the degree being the same the
degree being the same and all that's
different is a constant that's kind of a
little bit of a clue to you hey can you
get this you reshape this just bold it a
little bit so we're combined through ok
so if I write plus 2 minus 2 like so you
can see I can separate this numerator
into two pieces
yeah so what I'm going to get here is
that first piece is 2 plus sine theta 2
plus sine theta so that's the integral
of 1 with respect to theta
yeah then what you get over here is take
away take away what I can take out that
too if I want integral bar what get less
what's gets left there isn't one on so
you know sine theta no but it stays the
same
now I don't know what this is yet but at
least what I have done is take a more
complicated problem and sort of reshape
it so it's the same magnitude of
difficulty as ones that I already know
like a dude okay so that I think was the
hardest leap like leap in vertical means
the rest of this well let's see what
happens cuz still not nice and tiny and
beep there's still some fun things to it
ok so what is the integral of 1 with
respect to theta its Peter
what what variable am i dealing with you
okay now when you have a look at the
right-hand side now I'm ready to deal
with that through these two years olds
okay so I'm going to do the substitution
okay and then a little simplify it over
there so have I got here - - did you
roll off one on t + what
yep Davey
now hold on I need to change I need to
change the variable of integration right
so maybe I'll put it yeah I'll just put
it here to old 1 plus T sweat yeah times
DT or D theta D theta
cancel kids yep yes so this is a big
what kids think that I can do here
right what else could I do one other
options have I got yep good so I can see
this too and this pair of two's here I
mean there's two Tuesday no it doesn't
matter
maybe I should take this one because
inside the interior so if I cancel that
that means I can cancel that and this
becomes a 1 ok and you can see here oh
look I already have a one plus t-squared
when you write it like this is we just
want to play through ok so what am I
gonna end up with I've got thena hanging
out front don't forget that guy we don't
usually have it but don't make them
disappear to over to neutralize what
that's what I got from multiplying by
the one and that's what I got the
denominators cancel with respect to T
okay what was there now what are we
gonna do with this okay now it's not
immediately obvious because again if I
say go like this and extend this out
that's well I'll just put it in born up
yeah what is that what is that closest
to so this is Chris just attending us
know how to identify that if I were just
to cover that right then I can see all
of that so standard form so the
difference of having that there just
means I need to just shift this around a
little bit and I'll get a standard form
there's a couple of ways you can do this
the way that I ended up doing it was I
completed this way which some of you I
know have attempted it looks like it'll
be messy but stay with it okay and what
I've got is on the denominator if I've
got T squared plus T how do I complete
the square what do I do this yeah I'm
going to have this coefficient which
then then comes off and then I'm gonna
square them so I add 1/4 so that now
that's a square agree then of course
I've got 3/4 leftover in order to
complete the one yeah happy so far -
lots of now what is the actual
experiment t plus 1/2 squared plus 3/4
now that 3/4 I actually will write it in
a slightly different way as well it's
also I want that to be a square - right
what's the square root of 3/4
cool now I could then go and say okay
let u equal T plus 1/2 and then go ahead
and do the substitution but in this case
because my muse number reverse chain
rule is gonna be nice the coefficient
there the derivative of the inside which
I'm going to need for a rest chain rule
it's just 1 so I'm just gonna just just
go for it ok this is theta minus 2 this
is something squared plus root 3 or 2 or
squared right so this is going to be 1
on a you remember the one on me now
what's a these kids through the military
that's why I put it in the brackets and
sweater so this is one on a there's a
tan inverse of what's inside the
brackets so usually this would be an x
squared so we'd have X on a you but I
don't have X I've got T plus a ha and
again that's also divided by hey okay so
and now I'm on yeah over to render it so
know pretty much almost there let's just
tidy up a little bit you've got feet up
- that's good that - is going to come
into the numerator become a 4/4 turn off
okay what's in here
I'm gonna do two things so firstly I am
gonna replace the T with 10ft no - which
is what I said and the same time that
dividing by 2
underneath the dénouement it's actually
multiplying through by 2 so I'm gonna
write that like this one on root 3 tan
inverse I start to Taney mess it's on -
it's right
oh sorry of course it's 10 o'clock Jay
it's hot plus one on theta
somebody on exercise okay let's get the
move very well wrong twice okay with my
cousin right on the end what do you
think yes okay so a weird a weird thing
they do is the answer actually says from
memory I think they've got to 10 inverse
of tan theta well and to now I hope you
can see that's the dock right I guess
what they've done is they've got it all
in terms of
like this is sort of vastly inferior to
this but yeah what they've done you can
see why they've done it what they're
buddies this is really two tenemos of T
right so they've got a somewhere in here
they've got a one on one plus t-squared
yeah that's what they've got in there so
they've done they've separated their
fractions out in a Lima students come
from here they're separated they're
fraction C they've done partial
fractions you know we dismiss this
before but you end up in the same spot
okay
however I will say I mean I think I kind
of like our solution better I think
dealing with this like is vastly
superior and quicker and more efficient
than doing partial fractions the exactly
right you're like cool it's it's obvious
that that's where this rather than well
what about domain lava Bartok that's it